oh my god this is so cute it's oh wait
what today I'm gonna use three online
tip generators to try to find the
perfect gift for my girlfriend
after being together for so long you do
kind of start to run out of things to
kind of get because you know it's not
only just Christmas but it's birthday so
it's Valentine's Day I feel like I can
get a little bit more creative in this
Christmas and see what these online this
dinner is a can come up with the first
one is called press e but it doesn't ask
too many questions let's check it out
who is a lucky person you are gifting
for a girlfriend connects you the
occasion so Christmas their age 20 to 50
dollars I guess now I just press find my
gift oh that's kind of cool definitely
something I would love you're not sure
if my girl from one loved it this works
they'd actually give you the option to
try again or just wrap it up but just
for the sake of this experiment I'm just
gonna wrap this gift up kicks' calm this
is very cool so it only obviously three
questions technically in the script
generator I'd actually their gender
their age and lastly what were they the
most likely to be denied in their spare
time but it gives you multiple different
kind of categories in which you can kind
of choose phones I finally
decided to get some candies she likes
candles I think it's really cute so this
next one here is called gift Jim it asks
me about the character of my other
person I'm getting to get four so that's
pretty good that should help I'm feeling
good about this one oh this one gives
you a list of things which is kind of
cool it's a little more work with this
gift generators you have a little more
freedom
so for gifting I'm gonna go with this
unique necklace it's a signature
handwriting necklace so I think she'd
like that she wanted a nameplate for
awhile now and I think it's a creative
nameplate so for the first gift
generator prezi.com it acts a few
questions and it didn't seem to give me
a gift that would really be best for my
girlfriend it's not as specific as you
would like
gifts calm I found it to be the most
difficult I could have used a little bit
more guidance in help from gift Jen I
liked it because it gave you give you so
many different options to choose from it
doesn't really matter what I think
so I'm just going to go ahead and
purchase these and suus one is her
favorite call me Santa Claus because the
gifts are in the house man I can't wait
to see which one Shakya likes the best
hey babe I have a surprise for you oh
wait what okay
it's a headphone Stan I'm confused like
so it's just a Stan and it charges my
headphones or something or Oh has like
okay so it has like a little USB port
but I couldn't
I don't know what it does I definitely
liked it I liked it rather until I
realized that if you even come with the
headphones it's just a stand so now I'm
back to being confused when it comes to
technology I guess why I'm so so about
it it's it it it doesn't excite me that
much it's kind of an okay gift I love
candles
I definitely skip first or oh my god
wait this is actually nicer because it
comes with a remote this is pretty cute
like the fact that these are battery
operated so I can always kind of have
the ambience or like that kind of like
know the vibe and then I was over and I
love the fact that it has a freakin
remote guys alright anybody who likes
candid you know this is kind of cool
like okay guys thank you I honestly
would say out of all of the gifts I
definitely like this one the most for
sure the candles this was the second
gift that I open and I like it this okay
most in regards to the east and
I guess you can add this because what am
I supposed to do it did pretty well
well cannot connect can I tell you that
I actually didn't handpick these gifts I
should get these food generator really
well if you did that that's interesting
but I will say that I think it's kind of
accurate I wouldn't say it 100% clearly
not a hundred percent accurate but it's
it's pretty up there I want it
I wanted a necklace so this is on my
list I actually I have a list I gave it
to have Santa Claus says gee Thank You
Nana I think it guys can't front super
excited because she doesn't like the
headphone stand and guess who has some
headphones that need a stand
I'm about to go jazz on my desk at work
hallo